>> JOE BIDEN HAS ANOTHER HUGE
HEADACHE IN HIS GROWING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS SCANDAL.
HIS OWN ATTORNEY GENERAL FORCED
TO APPOINT A SPECIAL COUNSEL,
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE JOE WAS
LEAVING SECRET FILES ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
A SECOND TROVE OF DOCUMENTS WERE
FOUND IN HIS GARAGE IN
WILMINGTON, DELAWARE, RIGHT NEXT
TO HIS PRIZED MUSCLE CAR.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOWNPLAYING THE
DISCOVERY, AND USING THE CLASSIC
CORVETTE DEFENSE.
>> CLASSIFIED MATERIAL NEXT TO
YOUR CORVETTE.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
>> I'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO SPEAK
ON THIS GOD WILLING SOON, BY THE
WAY, MY CORVETTE IS IN A LOCKED
GARAGE.
NOT SITTING OUT ON THE STREET.
>> IN A LOCKED GARAGE?
>> YES, AS WELL AS MY CORVETTE.
AS I SAID EARLIER THIS WEEK,
PEOPLE KNOW I TAKE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL SERIOUSLY.
THEY DISCOVERED A SMALL NUMBER
OF DOCUMENTS WITH CLASSIFIED
MARKINGS IN STORAGE AREAS, IN
FILE CABINETS IN MY HOME AND MY
PERSONAL LIBRARY.
>> NO ONE EVER BREAKS INTO A
LOCKED GARAGE, BREAKS INTO A
GARAGE DOOR AND LEAVES IT OPEN.
TODAY THE DOJ DISCOVERED ANOTHER
DOCUMENT IN BIDEN'S HOUSE.
THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS CLAIMED
THEY WERE INADVERTENTLY
MISPLACED.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS HERE.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM ALL.
>> I REFER YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE OR MIRE COLLEAGUES IN
THE COUNSEL OFFICE.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO BEYOND WHAT
THE PRESIDENT SAID.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO THE
PARTICULARS OF THE DOJ DID.
THERE'S AN ONGOING PROCESS.
IT'S BEING REVIEWED.
DON'T HAVE MORE TO SHARE.
>> WAS IT BECAUSE --
>> AGAIN, THERE'S A PROCESS, AN
ONGOING PROCESS, THAT'S
OCCURRING.
>> OOH, THE PROCESS.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE VIEW AND A
DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN HAVE A
SOLID THEORY ON THE DOCUMENTS.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN A LUCKIER
PERSON WITH DONALD TRUMP.
JUST THIS CLOSE TO GETTING HIM,
AND SOMEHOW THESE DOCUMENTS
APPEAR.
>> DOES IT FEEL LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS ARE BEHIND IT?
>> IT DID ORIGINALLY, BUT -- I'M
SORRY -- BUT NOT NOW.
>> ALSO AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
THINGS CAN BE PLANTED ON PEOPLE.
THINGS CAN BE PLANTED IN PLACES,
AND THEN DISCOVERED
CONVENIENTLY.
THAT MAY BE WHAT HAS OCCURRED
HERE.
>> JOY OBVIOUSLY STEALING THAT
JACKET FROM MICHAEL KEATON IN
"BEETLEJUICE."
HOW DO WE NOT KNOW IT HASN'T
BEEN PLANTED, GERALDO?
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT COLLUDED
WITH TRUMP.
>> IT'S PREPOSTEROUS AND
RIDICULOUS, AS IS THE ENTIRE
SCANDAL.
THIS IS MUCH TO DO ABOUT
NOTHING.
THIS IS A CHANCE TO THE
REPUBLICANS GO, NA-NA-NA.
>> JOE DESERVES IT, GETTING UP
ON HIS HIGH HORSE.
>> I THINK BECAUSE OF HIS STERN
AND SELF-RIGHTEOUS AND INFLATED
OUTRAGE, FAUX OUTRAGE, OVER THE
PRESIDENT -- PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
MAR-A-LAGO STASH, THEN HE LOOKS
LIKE A HYPOCRITE THAT HE
APPARENTLY IS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S MOST
DAMAGING, HIS OWN HYPOCRISY.
>> IT'S SO AMAZING, DANA,
BECAUSE THE EVENTS HAPPENED SO
CLOSE.
WITH TRUMP, IT WAS IN AUGUST.
HERE IT IS NOW.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY,
IMAGINE IF THIS WAS TRUMP, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO IMAGINE IT,
BECAUSE IT ALREADY HAPPENED.
THEY DID CRUCIFY HIM.
>> I HOPE THAT THE MEDIA WILL
UPDATE ALL OF THEIR THIS ISN'T
AS BAD AS TRUMP VISUAL AIDS.
THIS STORY IS GROWING, AND WILL
GROW MORE.
I HOPE WE DO FIND OUT WHEN THE
DOCUMENTS WERE REVEALED, WHEN
DID THEY KNOW IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, ESPECIALLY IN THE PRESS
OFFICE, BECAUSE IF THEY WEREN'T
TOLD ABOUT THE NOVEMBER 2nd
DISCOVERY, THAT'S SOMETHING, OR
DID THEY DECIDE TO ALSO PLAY IT
DOWN AND NOT COMMENT UNTIL AFTER
THE MIDTERMS.
I DO THINK, YOU KNOW HOW BIDEN
SAID HOW IRRESPONSIBLE COULD YOU
BE.
>> UH-HUH.
>> THAT'S LIKE THE NEW -- WHAT
DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE, WHICH
WHAT -- THAT WAS THE THEME OF
THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN,
HOW IRRESPONSIBLE COULD YOU BE.
YOU COULD TAKE THAT LINE TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ON ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE ISSUE.
ANOTHER POINT IS THAT A LOCKED
GARAGE AS A DEFENSE.
IS HIS PASSWORD PASSWORD?
THAT'S NOT GOING TO CUT IT.
IMAGINE IF PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
THAT.
DON'T WORRY, MY WIFE'S CLOSET
HAS A LOCK ON IT.
THIS IS ABSURD.
THE OTHER THING IS, IT'S REALLY
BAD FOR THE GOVERNMENT AND FOR
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY DEAL WITH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
LAST FEBRUARY, THE GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY SECURED A PRISON TERM
FOR A FORMER DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
EMPLOYEE WHO MISHANDLED
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS.
IF YOU READ THIS CRIMINAL, A CNN
PIECE, SHE WAS WORKING ON A
THESIS, THEY NEEDED TO WORK ON
THE THESIS, COVID HAPPENED,
COULDN'T GET INTO THE BUILDING,
SHE TOOK A CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT
HOME, THEY HAD A DINNER PARTY,
AND ANOTHER COLLEAGUE SEIZED THE
DOCUMENTS AND TURNS HER IN.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
SHE'S IN PRISON.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
WHAT A FINK.
>> THAT'S HORRIFYING.
>> YOU KNOW, KENNEDY,
CONSPIRACIES PUT FORTH ON "THE
VIEW" SUGGESTING IT MIGHT BE
REPUBLICANS.
>> PROBABLY WAS, YES.
>> COULDN'T YOU ARGUE THAT IT'S
MORE -- IF THERE'S ANY
CONSPIRACY, IT WOULD COME FROM
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT BIDEN
TO RUN, WHICH IS 85% OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> AND MAYOR PETE.
>> TRYING TO TANK HIS CAMPAIGN,
THEY WOULD HAVE PLANTED THOSE
DOCUMENTS, PEOPLE WITHIN THE
BIDEN CIRCLE AT HIS PENN OFFICE
IN D.C., WILMINGTON, DELAWARE,
HOME, BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN,
BECAUSE GERALDO THINKS IT ISN'T
A BIG DEAL.
I THINK THEY ALL DO IT.
>> I THINK THEY DO TOO.
>> I THINK EVERY PRESIDENT HIDES
AWAY DOCUMENTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS TRYING TO
HIDE SOMETHING OR WAS
IRRESPONSIBLE.
HE DOESN'T KNOW HOW LONG THEY'VE
BEEN THERE, WHO PUT THEM THERE.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL TALKING ABOUT
TOP CLASSIFIED SECRET
INFORMATION.
WE SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT,
CONSIDERING SPIES SURROUNDING
DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, AFTER THE SPEAKER
DRAMA LAST WEEK, YOU CAN'T DENY
THAT THE MATRIX IS REAL, SOMEONE
IS WRITING EVERY CHAPTER.
I THOUGHT THIS WEEK WOULD BE
BORING, BUT NOW THERE'S A THIRD
TRANCHE OF DOCUMENTS.
THANK YOU, OVERLORD.
>> IT'S CLEAR JOE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON,
RIGHT?
B, THIS TO ME IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
HA-HA-HA.
>> THAT'S JOE'S DEFENSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN MY HOUSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN MY
OFFICE.
CHINA PUT IT THERE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DOCUMENTS
SAY.
IT'S THE IDIOT DEFENSE.
>> IT IS.
YOU START LOOKING AT THE STUFF
ABOUT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, AND IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING.
>> SO HE OPENS THE BIDEN CENTER,
AT UPENN, AND THEN SENDS THE
UPENN PRESIDENT TO BE THE
AMBASSADOR OF GERMANY.
THEN TALK ABOUT CHINA --
>> IF YOU TOOK THE CORVETTE,
DROVE IT TO TAIWAN, CHINA
WOULDN'T INVADE.
NOW, HAVE YOU EVER HAD A GARAGE
DOOR, YOU HIT THE BUTTON, AND IT
CLOSES, BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN IT
GOES BACK UP BECAUSE A LEAF IS
DANGLING INTO THE BEAM, AND IT
WON'T LET YOU CLOSE IT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE AT.
BIDEN'S AUTOMATIC GARAGE DOOR
OPENER IS THE SAFEST THING YOU
CAN HAVE.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU BEEN
DRIVING, CAN YOU IMAGINE HIM IN
THE CORVETTE, JILL, GOT TO TURN
AROUND,IC I LEFT THE GARAGE DOOR
OPEN.
DID THEY HAVE A GARAGE SALE?
I MEAN, HOW DO WE KNOW HUNTER --
OH, GUESS WHAT, MOM AND DAD ARE
IN REHOBOTH, BRING THE STRIPPERS
ARE OVER.
THESE THINGS ARE THERE FOR SEVEN
YEARS.
YOU'RE SAYING HUNTER DIDN'T
PARTY WHILE HIS PARENTS OUT,
DIDN'T HAVE THE CHINESE SPY
WORKING FOR THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
OVER AT THE HOUSE?
DID HE HAVE PATRICK HO, THE GUY
INDICTED FOR ESPIONAGE OVER AT
THE WHITE HOUSE?
WHAT BUSINESS PARTNER OF HUNTER
WENT OVER TO THE HOUSE?
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
ANYTHING WAS COMPROMISED, ZERO
EVIDENCE.
>> WE JUST STARTED THE
INVESTIGATION, GERALDO.
JOE BIDEN RAN HIS BASEMENT
CAMPAIGN FROM THE HOUSE, WHERE
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE.
HOW MANY CAMPAIGN STAFF MEMBERS
WERE GOING IN AND OUT OF THERE?
IS IT THE RUSSIANS?
OOPS, LOOK AT THESE UKRAINE
DOCUMENTS.
CLICK-CLICK.
IT'S SO EASY TO GET INTO THIS
SITUATION GERALDO.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
ALSO, BIDEN IS USING THE HILLARY
DEFENSE, WHICH I LOVE.
HE'S SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT, MY
LAWYERS, HAVE LOOKED INTO ALL OF
MY OFFICES, AND DETERMINED THESE
ARE THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TURN OVER.
THE REST OF THE DOCUMENTS WE
FOUND MOSTLY ABOUT HUNTER'S
WEDDING AND YOGA.
WHO GETS AWAY WITH THAT?
>> WOULD YOU CARE AT ALL IF IT
WASN'T FOR MAR-A-LAGO?
>> OF COURSE I WOULD CARE.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT MAR-A-LAGO.
I CARE ABOUT CAR-A-LAGO.
TRUMP IS UNDER INVESTIGATION BY
TWO SPECIAL COUNSELS.
BIDEN IS UNDER INVESTIGATION.
HIS SON IS UNDER INVESTIGATION.
SO THESE LAWYERS, WHO YOU KNOW I
HATE, ARE BASICALLY GOING TO
DETERMINE WHO THE NEXT
PRESIDENT'S GOING TO BE.
YOU CAN INDICT ONE, NOT THE
OTHER.
YOU CAN INDICT BOTH.
WHY ARE A HANDFUL OF LAWYERS AND
PROSECUTORS DETERMINE WHO THE
NEXT PRESIDENT IS?
THEY DID IT WITH HILLARY.
NOW THEY HAVE JOE AND HIS SON
UNDER LOCK.
I MEAN, THE FBI IS -- THESE
GUYS, IT'S TOO MUCH
INVESTIGATION.
THE.
>> CAR-A-LAGO?
>> TOOK ME ALL DAY.
>> GOOD FOR YOU.
>> THIS IS A DISTURBING TREND,
THAT BIDENS LEAVE STUFF
EVERYWHERE.
THEY LEAVE GUNS IN TRASHCANS,
DIARIES IN HALFWAY HOUSES, BABY
AND STRIPPERS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THE CHANCES
THAT THEY FIND MORE DOCUMENTS
AND MORE HOMES AND MORE OFFICES?
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES?
>> THE CHANCES, I SAY, ARE GOO